نرجع نقول انه في مشكله كثير من مؤسسات
الصحفيه طبعا احنا نتكلم من الصحافه اليوم
ليست فقط صحافه ورقيه سوف ورقيه نعتقد
مرحله اتت اكلها تنتهي هذه حاله طبيعيه
ولا فيها ما يغير هي الاشكاليه الاساسيه
في بعض المؤسسات
على مستوى العالم العربي اللي هو عدم
ادراك او التفاهم البطن تراخي او الجهل
يمكن فيه او التقشف على سبيل المثال لانه
عندهم وعدم تاهيل احيانا الممانعه على
هدول صحيح احنا بنتكلم على كان عندنا لكن
عند امه منعه طبيعيه لهذا التقدم
التكنولوجيا لانهم هم بالتالي الناس اداء
له
بالتالي انهيار جميله وخير بديل خلينا
نرجع لمساله شغف والقدره انه القدرات
الواحد من عنده كان هذه المرحله هي هي
تغيب الشمس عنها فبالتالي لما نتحرك ساكن
في الظلام
كثير احنا نقول انه جيل ممتاز اجيال
ممتازه لكن ايضا هذه الاجيال عدم قدرتها
على التفاعل والاستجابه والتغيير عدم
قدرتها على التغير
واللي هو الارتان او التناغم مع هذا
التحور الضروري بالتالي يبعدها عن المشهد
حاله العويل والبكاء على تراجع للمرحله